business is booming at kitty cat walks
and meow with more customers and
employees
they've got their paws on a whole lot
more sensitive data they know that
google cloud dlp will help them protect
that data and reduce their risk
but with so many transformation options
it could be a real challenge figuring
out which ones to use
and when today we'll talk about what
de-identification is
the factors to consider when choosing a
de-identification technique
and check out a few examples including
crypto based tokenization
[Applause]
de-identification is the process of
removing personal identifying
information from your data
common examples of personal identifying
information or pii
are credit hard numbers addresses phone
numbers
and names of course some parts of your
system might need access
information billing for example but
other parts do not
this is where de-identification with dlp
comes in
the dlp api can intelligently detect
sensitive information
and use a number of de-identification
transformation techniques
to mask delete tokenize or otherwise
obscure the data
choosing to write the identification
transformation will depend largely on
two things
first of all we're going to need to
consider what kind of data we want to
de-identify
are we going to try to de-identify dates
by using date shifting we can shift
date values by a random amount of time
or maybe we're trying to hide text from
images
well image redaction will work there dlp
uses info type detectors and optical
character recognition to find text and
image files and mask it with an opaque
rectangle
the second thing to consider is the
purpose for de-identifying the data
this is important because some
de-identification techniques will
completely hide sensitive values
while others will still allow you to
extrapolate important information about
the data
let's consider an example check out this
excerpt from a chat log between a
customer and a kitty cat walks customer
service rep
when we de-identify it using masking the
sensitive content is replaced by
a masking character like an asterisk or
hash symbol
there isn't much that we can deduce
about the information that's being
removed
[Music]
when it's de-identified using
replacement where it can be replaced by
something else like its corresponding
info type
we can at least know that what the
customer entered was an email address
in both cases we successfully removed
the personal information
but with replacement we can at least
tell what info type was removed
other techniques use bucketing to help
you generalize extinguishing values in
your data based on custom values or
ranges
this is especially useful for data meant
to be used for reports or for data
analysis
we'll be able to make use of the data
without exposing it unnecessarily for
example
when the finance department wants to
write a report on salary info
considering there's only one director of
cat naps it'd be easy for anyone looking
at this data to learn
what that person's salary is potentially
sensitive information
by applying bucketing here we're able to
use the financial data while protecting
the employee's privacy
another powerful de-identification
category worth noting is crypto based
tokenization
cloud dlp can securely encrypt sensitive
data using a cryptographic key
and replace it with a hash or a token
cloud dlp supports several types of
tokenization including some that are
reversible
so that you can even re-identify the
de-identified data
here's one more example we scan some log
files of kitty catwalk's issue ticketing
system and exported the results to
bigquery
you'll see that in the data column it
shows text that we've had replacement
applied on various info types
but check out the first column here we
apply tokenization
and sodomize the user id the values in
this column are unrecognizable
but if we run a query like this one to
give us a count based on the user id
we can see how many issues there are for
each unique user
this is accomplished without exposing
the value that we've replaced
so it can be used for data analysis
without risk of compromising user data
furthermore the user id values can be
re-identified by individuals or teams
are authorized to access the encryption
key
used to tokenize the values in the first
place
so which the identification technique is
the best choice for kitty cat walks to
protect their sensitive customer and
employee data
the good news is cloud dlp offers enough
de-identification options and
flexibility that they won't have to
prescribe a blanket policy for all their
pii
understanding the trade-offs of each
technique will empower them to get the
most value from their data
while protecting it every step of the
way next time we'll take a closer look
and examine
how some of these de-authentication
transformations work to protect and
secure your sensitive data
see you then
[Music]
you